I was afraid I couldn't live up to these
expectation you don't think you got your
validation for me this is the first time
having a sequel to anything so I was
really excited about building on the
characters you get people they need you
know the second one we wanted to make
things a little bigger bring him back
Ivan Drago and his son Victor and that
history that animosity with Creed and
rocky it just made it that much more
intense this guy is dangerous ain't got
a choice I just say that your father
said he died right here in my head you
can always relate to hundred dog story
to the person who's fighting for
something who has passion it was easy
they're gonna be a part of something
that was human if you want to fight this
man that's your business
but don't pretend this is about your
father Ryan Coogler suggested Stephen
and I was excited to work with Steve and
I was really looking forward to building
something with him yeah allocate we
understood it he just wanted to go the
distance
what a talented director he is I could
tell he was gonna be great for this
picture it's not just us anymore Dean
that's exactly why I can't lose steven
is very much his own voice and wants to
come in and tell his own story inside of
this I want to rewrite history that's
one of the challenges when you're
getting passed the torch by two
legendary filmmakers in semester's
Tyrone and Ryan Coogler have been very
helpful and if they're saying hey this
is what this world is like how do we
stay true that Wow
putting our own stamp on it to see it
played out in the new generation with a
new guy it was fantastic it may not seem
like it now
this is more than just fight this diva
has been a blast he's a really strong
leader and you want to follow
you gotta ask yourself what are you
fighting for
Adama screed has been challenged by
Victor Drago son of the man who killed
his father I'm taking the fight I should
say that your father said and he died
right here in my hands
this kid was raised in hate dangerous
this won't be the end to me
for you
because we're a team
Creed to rated pg-13
you